hey guys I'm on the road here and I just
stopped because um
I wanted to share this with you I've
just read earlier today
um that the world economic forum
have just said something that's crazy
that
you know it's the first time that we
live in a time where we create something
that can create new things AI
AI comes up with new ideas and I
actually said that it can write a new
Bible where people will follow a new
holy book written by AI
so
um these things will happen the closer
we get to the end times craziness is
taking over but it's more important than
ever to stick to sound Doctrine so read
your Bible stick to it and make sure
that you live in truth because if you
don't you live and practice a religion
that's just in your own head and made up
so let's stick to scripture stick to
God's word no matter what love you guys
bye